and let's bring in our excellent panel
of analysts Corey Lewandowski was the
manager of the Trump presidential
campaign and the co-author of the huge
bestseller let Trump beat Trump
Philippe Reyes is a former senior
advisor to Hillary Clinton and Fox News
contributor Charlie hurt is opinion
editor of The Washington Times and Fox
News contributor Byron York is a
reporter for The Washington Examiner
gentlemen it's great to see all of you
Corey let's start with you this to me
this seemed like Trump was turning the
corner from you know hard-charging
strong but it could be a little dark at
times and tonight it was optimism the
sky's the limit we can do anything for
America if we work hard I saw that turn
tonight which i think is important look
what he focused on he focused on
reminding the American people we were
just a year ago where the economy was
and where it is today with job creation
with unemployment for the Hispanic and
black community at record lows with
consumer confidence at record highs but
also he reminded our country that we
still have problems ms-13 is a problem
we had victims in the gallery there
whose family members were taken by these
horrible people and we have to do better
he talked about what he's done as it
relates to getting rid of Isis 98
percent of the territory they covered is
now gone this was supposed to be a
generational problems what barack obama
told us Isis was a generational problem
in one year ninety-eight percent of
their territory has been taken over
that's a lot less than a generation it
was a very good positive forward-looking
speech Philippe I thought it was a
robust defense of American
exceptionalism the Democrats had a hard
time standing at certain parts which I
thought was I thought was odd when we
talk about african-american unemployment
at unbelievable low and you can't get
Democrats standing for that I mean to me
that looks like you're cheering against
progress and that's why I think this new
poll that came out tonight is going to
put the Democrats upside down
97% according to CBS poll just came out
after the speech of Republicans rated it
well 43% of Democrats rated it good and
72% of independents gave it an A+
approval over
with 75 225 approving of Trump speech
well I think what President Trump did
tonight was he gave a traditional State
of the Union address and I actually
don't mean that as a compliment and I
don't mean it as a I was not so fully
but I don't mean it specifically snarky
to President Trump and I'll tell you why
the man that Cory got to the Republican
nomination is not the man who has done
it traditionally he has not left any
stone unturned up ended just smash and
that has worked for him the State of the
Union it seems to me the last bastion
that he respected as is and I'll tell
you why I think that might not have been
the best thing your numbers aside I
think what you had tonight was probably
well I'm not gonna pretend to understand
the Republican base probably a lot of
people who thought that that was flat
that was not the guy that they loved not
their fighting senator well they liked
it they've liked it but you know what
never in the huge in the history of man
has someone said hey remember last week
when the president said this in the
State of the Union address and they're
not going to next week and I actually
think that's a missed opportunity for
president Trump because he's a man who
has taken everything turned it upside
down and made it work for him he left
the State of the Union go as normal and
we're gonna forget about all due respect
to a CBS poll whoever it is we're gonna
forget about it he could have and should
have just been him because you know what
you guys think he did great dad
Phillippe you would be trashing him on
this but you know what Donald Trump was
it he was rich really he was acerbic he
was acidic he didn't bring the country
together which you loved when I go to my
crest fairs with my friends with their
coconut juice and we complained about
him without Deranger but they're not
this week and I say you know what are
you one of the 43% who liked him because
I'm changing my mind
it's a speak whatever lame I think that
a lot of people will remember in a week
and that is the one about all Americans
are dreamers and I think that was a very
important part of the message he was
trying to get across but my goodness I
mean when looking back at you know when
we were trying to predict how he's gonna
do this of course the guy he's such a
great showman of course he is going to
knock it out of the park in terms of
using these props these people these
American citizens that he brings in the
you know
regular ordinary Americans who do
extraordinary things whether it was the
whether it was the North Korean guy with
crutches which was just absolute gut
punch show that do you have that clip I
want to show the clip I mean we'll show
it in a minute did you know that I mean
and I think that was a very important
obviously a very important part of the
message he's trying he's trying to sort
of put Americans on notice that this is
a very serious issue and that that you
know that there are real consequences at
stake here but all the other that you
know the cop who adopted the baby from
the meth mother the meth addict and the
soldier who saved his buddies like these
were really powerful stories that I and
and we should have known that a guy a
showman like this would do a good job I
thought was interesting guys and Byron I
want to hear from you on this we came
off we just came off of the Grammy
Awards where the celebrity culture was
so you know incredibly antitrump and
everybody feels good but trash and Trump
and that's fine then he brings on which
other presidents have done ordinary
heroes American citizens or or mothers
or fathers who he mentioned who just
work hard every day to support their
families and ones who have sadly been
brutalized by government failures to
enforce our border and I point to the
ms-13 victims in Long Island and those
two families say I of course I start
bawling is I I just couldn't I couldn't
hold back the tears watching those
families you don't often see the victims
of that type of crime you see a
newspaper short article but Byron I'd
like you to speak to that because I
thought that for women especially
watching tonight I thought that was a
really powerful testament yeah he was
very effective in using the people that
he had invited and he used actually the
the two parents who had lost each lost a
daughter to ms-13 he used it basically
to introduce his his immigration section
which I'm sure enraged a lot of
Democrats one thing that was kind of
interesting that the White House had
been doing kind of some head fakes
during the day about how this is gonna
be a very you know
sighing speech and it really wasn't it
you could not have a better example of
the saying elections have consequences
the reason Democrats were sitting on
their hands during all this is because
it was clear that President Trump was
doing exactly the opposite of everything
they had hoped to do on taxes on
immigration on foreign policy on
regulation on judges on every single
thing this was a very very Republican
Trump speech which is why the
Republicans are jumping up every ten
seconds and the Democrats really really
had nothing to cheer I also in saying
that he wasn't Republican enough I will
say this all of these speeches are too
long I'm sorry they should all be cut by
twenty minutes at least I mean they
could be 15 minutes five zero and he
could have all well it's not like Obama
didn't go on and on and on and on I mean
they're all too long this is not a
partisan comment Philippe believe it or
not gonna comment my friend this is
Nicole Wallace earlier tonight Corey
this one's for you let's watch what it
revealed Donald Trump's deep and almost
sort of sad obsession with being liked I
mean he is always performing for the
audience watching no because because
people who are politicians aren't
interested in performing I'm not sure
what politics she's been she's been
covering but part didn't cold not like
when he talked about the American flag
when he talked about the twelve were a
boy who was going back and remembering
the soldiers who didn't have flags at
their grave was that the part that she
didn't like did she not like the part
that we moved the capital and recognized
Jerusalem that which part did Nicole
actually take exception with and the
answer is there is none because the
message that Donald Trump outlined
tonight is the message a talked to on
the campaign which is we're going to put
America first I know it's a novel idea
to some people I know they'd rather live
in another country I know the members of
the mainstream media said they promised
to move if Donald Trump got elected
guess what they're still all here this
y'all getting rich and they don't love
the fact that we have a president is now
proud to call America the greatest
country in the world again there was a
part of the speech that I referenced
earlier Phillipe where the Democrats it
was just so it was palpably weird
I'm sorry that they didn't react I want
to play it it's the first soundbite on
our sheet let's watch I call upon all of
us to set aside our differences to seek
out common ground and to summon the
unity we need to deliver for the people
this is really the key these are the
people we were elected to serve
[Applause]
african-american unemployment stands at
the lowest rate ever recorded
and Hispanic American unemployment has
also reached the lowest levels in
history
phillipe the resistance is you know
obvious in those clips I mean that they
don't recognize him as a legitimate
president would you concede that he's
not a legitimate president so they're
just gonna give up in the whole idea of
governing it's not gonna be a debate
about policy there's not going to be a
debate about well if you tweak the tax
cut this way would see point seven
percent more GDP in the third quarter
they've dispensed with all of that they
are just not going to govern with the
Republicans that's my sense we express
their disagreement with him the way some
Republican lawmakers did in 2009 to
President Obama by getting up and
yelling you'll I mean one person Joe
well not a me not the entire believe me
one person said yell do you lie we'd
have an 18 hours special edition of
Laura Ingraham angle Congressional Black
Caucus sitting down for the lowest
african-american employment in recorded
history now but I can't say not liking
President trumpet why wouldn't that be
something that you would plot in my
point to you is they're not afraid of
him failing they're afraid of him
succeeding because that means
conservative populism at the Trump
variety grows the economy and helps all
people I'm gonna go on a limb and say
that the Congressional Black Caucus has
a better insight into what's best for
blacks like four of us really for us and
that they in total do not think that
President Trump has been good for their
community I don't think that they are
sitting on their hands as you called it
to make some kind of point despite the
note their nose on their face it doesn't
make any sense
Charlie I just have a hard time thinking
that you know the whole notion and
politicians all politicians do this but
Democrats do it I think worse than
Republicans do about dividing people in
race and color and all that kind of
stuff but I mean jobs for everybody is
good whether you're black or white or
Hispanic or whatever unemployment
dropping is a good thing and and so I
think that actually it's kind of a petty
thing to have these guys on their hands
you know over say that's it in the end
it doesn't matter I was surprised that
there weren't more actual interruptions
but you know the
Trump throughout and he did this
throughout the campaign it's why one and
he did it tonight and any and he came
back to it at the end where he said that
above all else they are all Americans
and this capital this city and this
nation belongs to them and it it's
strange it that's still a radical idea
around here but it is and it's why
people like him and it's why people
around here don't get why people like
him
Byron returning power to the people that
was a theme during his campaign but you
know it was combative during the
campaign and I've been saying for some
time I know others have written it that
we needed Trump to take that turn to the
more optimistic and I think tonight and
I could pick out seven or eight points
in this speech where you really started
to see that okay we're focusing the
prize is for everybody this is a land of
freedom and opportunity and if you work
hard and play by the rules you will get
ahead and I think it was high time that
he made that turn and I think that's
where you might start seeing those
numbers go up you're already starting to
see him go up 43 percent approval and
his numbers on the economy are now
flipped up the right way according to
the Real Clear Politics average that's
good stuff for him you're right it is
time for him to make that turn you know
it's interesting we've been talking
about how unhappy and sour the Democrats
look during this whole thing but let's
look at the Republicans here they seem
like a pretty happy group very very
supportive of the president earlier in
the day Mitch McConnell had said 2017
was the best year for conservative
principles that he had been in Congress
and you just you you you mentioned the
the CBS poll of near-unanimous
Republican support for this I think that
this speech was also very good for
solidifying Republican support he had it
on the hill but it's always better to
have more so I think just as you look at
the Democratic unhappiness look at the
Republican unity in response to this
speech look at the Republicans are
really miserable for you know years and
years during Obama so it's like you know
we all have our turn I guess being
miserable sitting through State of the
Union speech